why is that you again oh how did you get
in here
I'm Greg I'm John welcome to the real
reject welcome hey John hey what honest
trailers has an honest trailer out for
an honest trailer oh boy
for what really like a town its trailer
about an honest trailer it's weird it's
a bit a little strange so this was
requested by a few first when I saw come
in and Tom nizette show Raja I agam into
mitzva reginae again yeah that's the
type of operation that you have to
perform operation when you have too many
testicles and you got to get one of them
removed for Colin and robbing that's all
over California we love them
after admin asked the question
you ever watch Iron Man but small
Marvel's latest solo movie invite you to
ask another you ever watch Iron Man on
WE Doctor Strange hahaha fear another
grand illusion that you haven't seen
this movie before
as you send a relic or just fill a cocky
but capable super rich wisecracking
workaholic with a weird goatee in love
with a redheaded subordinate learning to
be like Thunder plagued by a fake
Sherlock Holmes actor it's like Iron Man
but actually that's it it's pretty much
just like Iron Man has come as a moral
universe Wow
and not that it's just science but yet
the Thor went on about your own cousins
called it magic
and you pull the plug we're talking acid
trip seventies blacklight poster magic
eyes that says space and time and do
plot breaking ways and uses mind-blowing
effects to distract you from the fact
that the action is still 90% pudgy gin
that hurt his hand you cringe when he
tried to do a semi accident Todd didn't
go I forgot to set the clock I'm sorry
mom you weren't sure if he was serious
when he attempted a Boston I got no I've
done great this he of doing so well now
Benedict Cumberbatch will sound like an
Englishman pretending to be a servant
pretending to be in America up to Ron's
Gruber's accent and die hard when he
gets caught by Bruce Willis please
you can come on don't you Benny
Bubbe your natural voice is perfect use
it
join the titular strange on its journey
from acts one protagonist to act three
protagonists are side characters and
buildings who are up to the neutral
model standard cue tell Ejiofor it was
just kind of there to explain things
temporal immigrations can create
branches in time isn't the relic the
Typhoon's protect the world and we still
serve protect the sentiments badge
Mickelson playing a bad guy with weird
eyes for the third time in his career
whose entire plan we've also not
successfully ripping some pages out of a
book to summon a level of deeply hopes
one enslave the human race not repine
Phyllis when doing a being of immense
power bravely guarding the Marvel
Cinematic Universe from Asian actors is
cosmic and disclose with more
personality to any of the human beings
[Music]
close stop okay I want to see that cloak
crossover with a rug in Latin so bad
enjoy a visual masterpiece that has to
be seen in 3d on a giant screen to be
fully appreciated because when you watch
it on a laptop you realize just how much
of it it's medical mumbo-jumbo we need
to get a purpose of suboccipital
craniotomy I'm shooting transected
spinal cords of stimulating your Genesis
and the central nervous system passes
send down the brachial artery of the
radial atomistic complete c7 c8 spinal
cord injury with the eating side or of
magic mumbo jumbo but not to mention
makes them more powerful in the middle
dimension so delicious little cooking
area you're sure it was faster for my
descriptions one level to be multi meets
about four pages like a semester a
ritual to contact the Marvel and draw
power from the Dark Dimension
when Guardian will set me sideways as is
unnecessary issue laser beams out of
your want to be done with it
so enjoy a film that despite its faults
doesn't fall to the third act trap of
battling a CGI army in the sky being
saving money I didn't have the same
scene 13 times in a row the pardon and
sends a powerful message to the children
modern medicine can't be trusted and
somehow the bodies heal yes and don't
text and drive because you might end
attorney - a wizard star benedict long
than it is wide
Bordeaux Morpheus you lads bro night
nurse circle hands
hands-on hands-on hands-on things on top
corner and Ricky Bobby head
[Music]
I'm not sure what to do with my hand
stranger things
so Cumberbatch did the motion capture
for Dormammu himself man he really likes
to do revelry at our time no I mean kind
of shocked me
hey screen jam Hollywood's caught on not
done with you yet
click the Box on the left to watch
Benedict Cumberbatch enter our silly
questions in our honest interview or
click the Box on the right to see where
our cumber question again in the honest
trailer for Sherlock and please stop
yelling at us about aluminum we get it
Dormammu I come to bargain Dormammu ah
to bargain dude
to bargain that's probably the greatest
uh reading from a request they've done
yeah yeah absolutely a play I do there
at the end they got old Juan Bailey over
there I didn't realize the judge strange
environment for this really I saw all
the similarities they're talking I
didn't notice like there's something
like the nurse and everything like that
bi got a similar Pepper Potts for some
reason that didn't click with me I guess
I wasn't thinking about like lucky
wasn't like yeah yeah rich in origin
artistic dude who gets into an accident
that leads to him becoming a superhero
yeah exactly living to Humble himself
and care more about other people connect
with the one that he truly loves these
kind of kept at a distance then I don't
learn about responsibility good formula
it's a good Marvel formula man it's it's
super I get it I didn't see august osage
cam august osage county since age can
Osage County hosted so whatever shows
st. you [ __ ]
I don't know everybody put emphasis on
the
I don't that accident that we saw
briefly in this trailer was pretty bad I
couldn't tell if it was just like it's
so weird to see him talking with such a
distinctly different accent like if I
watched this movie maybe I'm getting
used to it I thought was a little weird
in black mass when he did it we had a
Boston accent I was gonna ask about that
because I know you saw him yeah it's a
little bit strange because it's French
so uh because there is any benedict
cucumber has such a distinctive voice
already he does that it's like I don't
want to hear them with doing another
voice just do your voice I don't hear
what character you do I don't agree with
that I completely agree with that good
at changing his list not at least for
this it was I was like I'm dr. strange
and I wasn't distracted for dr. strange
no I like them a lot of dr. strange
about his voice is perfect I don't know
where you're comparable a boy you got
stick with your guns when you give an
opinion I know I should have actually
have conviction Vinny hanging what
you're saying just tell me what to think
you know agreement okay I think this
movie is interesting because I did feel
that it follows a typical marbled beat
sheet it follows the origin format that
we've all recognized from previous zones
prior to watching Doctor Strange in but
it's one of those films where it's more
about the overall execution because it's
really fun it's very visually exciting
Benedict Cumberbatch is great a lot of
people can probably nitpick it and go
well this is just similar to Iron Man
and other Marvel origin tales but
specifically Iron Man still though
besides that once it's like people who
watch la la la or like ah this trips not
that great but everything else is great
but I like because it was one thing
that's how I kind of feel open people
talk [ __ ] on Doctor Strange it's just
like a kiddie movie it's just a typical
Marvel film I don't agree with that I
think if there's a lot of unique things
brought to this film well yeah I think
there's a it's the other half it's like
yeah there's a ton of stuff that we've
seen before from Marvel but it's an
origin story and there are only so many
ways to do that right now I agree is
like they brought in a whole other half
of stuff that seems like it was totally
new they brought in a different type of
philosophy they brought in a different
kind of imagery they brought in you know
the
mysticism and magic like even if there
are a lot of like plot mechanics that
are similar to iron managed to pass
movies like I thought they at least
really distinct defied the toned dark
string yeah look in the world like they
it's still expansive to me even if it's
not like a revolutionary story structure
you know I like to vibe a lot in that
movie
I like the journey is different from our
men the journey is sort of like being
selfless and giving as a whole like
giving up the south for the community
you know it's a different kind of thing
you know and belief the power of belief
whereas iron man kind of just gets to be
selfish and is just like yeah am Iron
Man
[ __ ] it you can live at the top of this
tower well no iron man does learn to be
easy is very self-absorbed but then he
becomes a hero but not in the same way
the [ __ ] train travels from America so
I think Afghanistan with his suit first
time he's rockin it to go out and kill
some bad guys kill some terrorists to
save these people who are being hurt
then he comes back my thought is they
all he really is movie yeah they all do
that but I get the sense that like
Doctor Strange the light philosophy is
different at the end of the day Tony
gets to do his [ __ ] and I don't feel
like talk to strange life is anymore is
about just doing me you know yeah he's a
member of an order now you know but it
is similar to in the sense of how like
they go disappearing for a very long
time and I come back well I never minded
me to like you know Batman Begins and
stuff work yeah go off and you train and
you become very focused that's a
different like you know Iron Man he just
is already smart yeah I just build ship
for a different reason I know this on
its trailer is going to get a lot of
people to request that they do a
stranger things one now hmm I think they
should do a stranger things one I go
watch strangest things I guess I were in
it man you're behind on everything I'm
better than you you are you heard it
here folks
greg alba better than me since 1998
before that though every kill out of
killing the game from ages zero seven
eight years is that on your aching you
no one could stop me it was totally on
top i want to repress sending some
requests honest trailers for what i
think they should do i think i should
you pulp fiction zero dark thirty zero
dark thirty united ninety
solo yeah definitely
lars von trier an anti-crime an
expectorant
Serbian nymphomaniac serbian film
Cannibal Holocaust
you know films everyone seen and loved
Vienna you know why did you reach a lot
of the footage easily and not get in
trouble when you do everything is gonna
be a good honest trailer split that
would be an interesting on its trailer
actually and I'm sure that they would
bring bring forth some some you know
interesting questions about the way the
plot of movie folks always interested to
see it honest trailer for a movie like
that that has like twisty turny what
these they do an honest trailer of coop
John Bailey is John Bailey is a voice
actor he's the host of honest trailers
he has his own YouTube channel he plays
Shane and walking deadly shame The
Walking Dead and the Punisher he's
hilarious he's married has a family what
people don't know about this guy is that
he's a thieving pervert he is he's a
thieving pervious steals contra it's
constantly he doesn't do any of his own
voice the [ __ ] klepto
no all he does is steal other people's
voices and on top of that two major porn
egg your honor here at first guys yeah
write that down send it to John Bailey
at John Bailey don't tell him I told you
this and don't tell him this video
exists nobody knows what John Bailey's
real voice sounds like no isn't that
scary who is who he is Gary guy he's
constantly doing accents and impressions
over Adam that was actually true alright
guys who subscribe it screen junk do it
subscribe to the regex
John's reasons to Jerry and he's also
the social media manager of Blum how to
be diggity and the real reject the night
the real rejects tonight from Clash and
say hey that's what we should call our
fans reject the night reject tonight
that's pretty cool get like a cool
shield for editor pontiff reject makes
them feel like they're not accepted
reject the night yeah reject us are I'm
sure is rejected source rejection